we all have our own demons you used to  be one thing no there's something else  are you gonna behave yourself no I have  no problem is used to ground will only  hurt the bad people  so many sucks so little time Eddie you  look lousy  I have a parasite I'm Eddie Brock I'm  the reporter now I always seem to find  myself questioning something the  government may not be looking at I found  something really bad  look around in the world moody see a  planet on the brink of collapse  human beings are disposable like men and  symbiote a mind this is a new race your  species the higher life-form  [Applause]  we cannot just hurt people  we have a deal I so many thanks from the  little time  that power it's not completely awful you  have no idea how much you're steering me  right now a walk away  and you just might survive guys you do  not want to do this trust me  we'll always come at a cost  [Music]  rolling down the street oh I have a  parasite yeah name is Chen  [Applause]  [Music]